just in the last week or so there's been
a couple of interesting stories from
space both involving water in space in
one way or another so we thought we have
a quick chat and tell you about those so
the first one is is that it's the
classic water story in some ways which
is water on Mars it's something that
people have been fascinated about for
centuries I guess when people first
thought there might be canals on Mars
then that introduced the idea there
might be water on Mars and the
fascination obviously fundamentally
arises from the fact that we think that
water is sort of fundamentally
associated with life and there's the
best evidence today of liquid water on
the surface of Mars has just been
released this is a space probe out there
at the moment the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter NASA probe which has been taking
pictures of the surface of Mars for some
years now Martian years now and one of
the things that they've recently
discovered is that on some hillsides on
Mars in winter there's nothing much
going on and then in the Martian spring
you start finding these little sort of
dark streaks appearing on these
hillsides and as you follow them through
the summer months you find the streaks
get longer and longer and sometimes they
bifurcate they split into two sometimes
they merge together and for all the
world they look like little trickles of
water running down the hillside this is
molten arrow that you can see running on
the surface of Mars which means that you
know when it's it's not there on the
surface it must be very close to the
surface and so the idea now is that if
you're finding this this much water on
the surface if you could actually dig
down the bit then potentially there
could be great reservoirs of the stuff
down there there is a one interesting
issue which is if you kind of figure out
what the surface temperature and
atmospheric pressure and so on on Mars
is likely to be they shouldn't really be
any liquid water on the surface it
should still be frozen it's very cold
still and so the only way you can
actually make it that there is actually
liquid water on the surface of Mars is
if it isn't pure water if it has to be
brine it has to be very salty water
because if you add salt to water it
lowers the freezing temperature
considerably and although salty water is
not very conducive to life there are
actually quite a lot of bacteria here on
earth that really thrive in a salty
environment and so the idea is that if
you're really looking for life on Mars
the best bet at the moment is that
they're likely to be these sort of salt
loving bacteria living in these trickles
of water how come we're never catching
the smoking gun it just seems too weird
that we never actually see it we always
just missed it by
few hours I think it's at least in part
that people are very conservative about
where they land things because you want
to make sure when you land a probe on
Mars that it's not going to tip over
when it lands that it's not going to
fall down a ravine and so on so people
tend to pick fairly dull places to land
and not surprisingly the exciting stuff
like running water and so on tends to
happen in the hilly places and the more
exciting places so as we get a bit more
adventurous or start building probes
that can actually travel larger
distances on Mars I think we will
actually find these things but I it is
just this effect that you tend to be a
bit conservative where you put them down
which means that you tend to pick the
dull places so not surprisingly the
place turns out looking a little bit
dull as well and how come whenever they
see evidence of liquid flowing they
always say it's water couldn't be other
liquids that cause these little rivets
and erosion on the sides of hills it
could be they're all that many materials
that are actually liquid at those kind
of temperatures so there aren't a huge
number of things to choose from and
because both hydrogen and oxygen are
very abundant in the universe the most
likely thing that you're going to find
running on the service is going to be
water it really is odds on that they
have found water now I don't think it's
not one of those things that someone
who's going to come up with an
alternative explanation I suspect quite
how important it is for you know life on
Mars and those kinds of things remains
to be seen but now it's interesting
story soon
it is related to water but actually let
me start with oxygen oxygen is a very
abundant element in the universe one of
the most abundant there is and yet
bizarrely astronomers have never
actually found molecular oxygen anywhere
in the universe we can find it in other
compounds carbon monoxide for example
exists a lot that's carbon and oxygen
together but oxygen on its own Oh two
oxygen plus oxygen has never been found
before except here on earth yes and I've
out there in space I meant to say yes
and so people have tried to come up with
explanations as to why they can't find
it and that's where we come back to
water again
because the authorities that probably a
lot of the oxygen out there is actually
locked up in water and then you can't
then see lots and lots of water because
that water is then frozen as ice and if
you take those take that ice and put it
on the surface of little grains in space
so you have these little sort of sand
grains and dust grains that are cut or
covered in in little icy coats then
they're very chemically nonreactive and
so actually you don't see very much
going on and you're not going to produce
molecular oxygen from those so someone
come up with a clever experiment to
actually try and and detect it for the
first time which is if this story is
right and all that water is out there so
all the oxygen is locked up in water on
these dust grains if you look at
somewhere where those little icy coats
are being melted away and so it's turned
back into liquid water then when you've
got liquid water you have much more
chance of chemical reactions then so you
can then convert some of that oxygen
from the water into molecular oxygen
there's a chance to detect it so what
the these guys are done with the
Herschel Space Telescope the ISA mission
that monitors the universe in the
infrared is looked at some star forming
regions for the signature of oxygen of
course in a star forming region you've
got lots of new stars forming which are
heating up their environments which
means if there are any of these little
frozen grains out there the water will
get melted on the surface of them so the
hope was well if we look at these star
forming regions we'll actually see that
water melting away and then some of it
being converted into oxygen so we can
actually do take the oxygen and sure
enough when they actually did the
experiment they found for the first time
the clear signature of oxygen in the
data that they were taking so you have
to do spectroscopy now so you have to
split the light up into a spectrum and
then because the oxygen molecules absorb
particular wavelengths of light and
re-emit particular wavelengths of light
you can find those signatures in the
spectral that very particular
wavelengths of light from the spectrum
might be missing entirely or you might
have an extra excess at a particular
wavelength even though these are what
for astronomers are quite dense regions
because the stars forming there it's
still comparable to the best vacuums you
can get on earth so no there's tiny
amount of oxygen you certainly wouldn't
want to be out there trying to breathe
it